Así que tal vez sepas, o tal vez no sepas
que cualquier ecuación lineal
puede escribirse en la forma
"y" igual a "mx" más "b"
donde "m" es la pendiente de la línea,
la misma pendiente de la que hemos estado hablando en los últimos vídeos,
¿no? que es el cambio en "y"
entre el cambio en "x"
y "b" es la intersección con el eje "y"
o también se le conoce como ordenada al origen,
¿ok?
así que la forma en que verificamos esto último,
es si sustituimos con "x" igual a 0
¿ok? si "x" es igual a 0,
eso significa que estamos justo en el eje "y"
si "x" es igual a 0,
entonces tenemos que "y" es igual a "m" por 0
más...
más "b"
"m" por 0 es simplemente 0,
no importando qué sea "m"
y entonces nos queda que "y"
es igual a "b"
así que el punto 0, "b" está en esa línea,
así que 0, "b"
esta línea va a intersecar
al eje "y" en el punto "y" igual a "b"
y eso vamos a seguirlo
checando en los siguientes vídeos.
Ahora para verificar que "m" es realmente la pendiente,
vamos a intentar con otros números,
así que ya sabemos que este punto está en la línea
ahora vamos a ver qué pasa si "x" es igual a 1
¿ok? lo que obtenemos es "y" igual a "m" por 1
que es "m" más "b"
y ahora ya sabemos entonces que el punto 1, "m" más "b"
está en la línea
¿ok? entonces este simplemente es el valor de "y",
¿cuál es la pendiente entre estos dos puntos?
bueno si tomamos el punto final como...
este el 1, "m" más "b"
entonces tendremos la "y" final
menos  "y" inicial, que en este caso sería "b"
sobre el cambio en "x" que es
eh... 1 menos 0  que es el del punto inicial, muy bien,
este es nuestro cambio en "y" sobre el cambio en "x"
y estamos usando dos puntos
el 1, "m" más "b" es el punto final
el 0, "b" es el punto inicial
entonces esto simplemente
nos queda "m" entre 1 que es, "m"
así que espero que esto ya, satisfaga tú  interés
ya, digo a lo mejor estas variables están un poquito abstractas pero definitivamente esto es más claro.
Ahora, lo que queremos hacer en este ejercicio es mirar estas gráficas
y usarlas, usar todo lo que ya conocemos...
sobre estas gráficas, para determinar cuál es la ecuación de las líneas.
¿ok? entonces vamos a empezar con esta linea "a" primero
¿cuál es la pendiente de "a"?
¿cuál es la pendiente de a?
bueno, a ver vamos a empezar en algún punto arbitrario
¿ok?  digamos este ok...
y entonces...
queremos encontrar números enteros así que,
déjenme moverme tres unidades a la derecha
así que nuestra delta "x" va a ser 3
¿y cuál va a ser nuestro cambio en "y"?
nuestro delta "y"
bueno, es...
bajamos 2 unidades ¿verdad?
2 cuadritos
entonces como bajamos es, -2
así que para "a" el cambio en "y"
sobre el cambio en "x" que es la pendiente,
nuestro cambio en "x" es 3
y arriba nos queda -2 que es el cambio en "y"
así que nuestra pendiente es, -2/3
¿ok? nos movimos 3 en "x" y bajamos 2 en "y"
así que la pendiente es, -2/3.
por ejemplo si nos moviéramos uno a la derecha, bajaríamos 2/3 ¿ok?
entonces ya tenemos la mitad de este problema
esta es nuestra "m"
Y ahora vamos a ver cuál es la intersección
con el eje "y" la ordenada al origen,
bueno ¿donde se intersecta? ya habíamos dicho que la pendiente es 2/3 ¿no?
entonces si desde este punto
me muevo 1 a la derecha
estoy bajando 2/3,
así que lo que me resta es 1/3,
este punto por lo tanto es el, 1 1/3 o bien 4/3
¿ok? es un poquito más que 1
así que "b" es igual a, 4/3
y ya sabemos que la ecuación es "y" igual a "mx"+"b"
en este caso "m" es
menos 2/3 que multiplica "x"
más "b" que es, 4/3
esa es la ecuación "a"
vamos a hacer la ecuación "b"
espero, que ya no tengamos que usar
tantas fracciones en este caso,
así que vamos a tratar de ver cuál es la pendiente primero.
Vamos a tomar un punto razonable digamos este...
Déjenme hacerlo por acá abajo,
la ecuación "b"
ok bueno nuestra delta "x" va a ser igual a
déjenme escribirlo así...
delta "x" es igual a,
si nos movemos 1 a la derecha...
¿ok? entonces si delta "x" es igual a 1
subimos 3 unidades ¿verdad?
en en la dirección "y"
así que nuestra delta "y"
nuestro cambio en "y" va a ser 3
así que, cuando nos movemos
1 unidad a la derecha
tenemos que, nuestro cambio en  "y" es 3
así que la pendiente simplemente queda como 3.
Ahora ¿cuál es la intersección con el eje "y"?
bueno, pues simplemente se intersectan en
"y" igual a 1 así que "b" va a ser igual a 1
y este fue bastante más fácil
finalmente "y" va a ser igual a "3x" más 1
vamos a hacer ahora esta otra línea,
la línea "c"
muy bien, la línea "c"
primero vamos a hacer ahora la
intersección con el eje "y"
así que inmediatamente
vemos que se intersecta en -2
así que "b" es igual a -2
ahora ¿cuál es la pendiente?
bueno, el cambio en "y"  entre el cambio en "x"
vamos a empezar aquí,
digamos en la intersección,
si nos movemos 2...
o bueno vamos a movernos 4 a la derecha,
para que vean un poquito más interesante esto
entonces ¿cuál fue nuestro cambio en "y"?
tenemos que subimos 2 unidades
entonces, el cambio en "y" simplemente fue 2
y el cambio en "x"  fue 4
entonces 2 entre 4 es lo mismo que 1/2
así que finalmente la ecuación es "m"
que es, 1/2 por "x"
-2 que es nuestra "b"
y ya acabamos
ahora vamos a hacerlo en otro sentido,
ahora tenemos las ecuaciones
de las líneas y queremos eh...
Esto está en su forma "mx" + "b"
dependiente con ordenada al origen.
Ahora vamos a hacer la figura...
con esta primera, cuando "x" es igual a 0
tenemos que "y" es igual a 5
es decir, nuestra ordenada al origen es 5
y está por aquí, así que aquí está
nuestra intersección
y la pendiente es 2
eso quiere decir, que cuando me muevo 1 en la dirección "x"
me muevo 2 hacia arriba en la dirección "y"
así que me muevo 1 y subo 2
me muevo 1 a la derecha subo 2
o bien, también si me voy uno atrás bajo 2
si me muevo otro atrás bajo 2
ok y sigo haciendo eso verdad, así que esta línea
se va a ver algo como de este estilo
este es mi mejor intento ok, y se seguirá
de esta forma hacia abajo
esa es nuestra primera línea
puedo seguir haciendo eso hacia abajo tanto como quiera, así que vamos a la segunda línea,
aquí es -0.2x más 7
"y" igual a, -0.2x más 7
así que siempre es más fácil pensarlo como fracciones
0.2 es lo mismo que, -1/5 ¿verdad?
por "x" + 7 así que sabemos que la
intersección es 7
la intersección con el eje "y" aquí está la
intersección cuando "x" es igual a 0
y esto nos dice que por cada 5 unidades que nos movemos a la derecha, subimos...
¡perdón! bajamos una unidad en "y"
así que, lo podemos ver como -1 entre 5 ¿verdad?
esto es delta "y" sobre delta "x"
y por cada 5 que nos movemos a la
derecha nos movemos 1 hacia abajo
así que por ejemplo aquí van 5 y bajamos 1
ahora 1, 2, 3, 4, 5 a la derecha bajo 1
o bien, si nos vamos hacia atrás
es decir, si tenemos que nuestro
cambio en "x" es, menos 5
entonces nuestro cambio en "y" va a ser 1
estas fracciones son equivalentes ¿verdad?
nos vamos 1, 2, 3, 4, 5 y subimos 1
vamos para atrás, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5 subimos 1
así que la línea se va a ver más o menos así
sólo tengo que conectar los puntos
ok, espero tengas la idea porque no es la
mejor línea que he pintado
pero bueno, ahora vamos a hacer este otro
"y" igual a menos "x"
y entonces ¿dónde está el término "b"?
no veo ningún término "b" así que acuérdense
que es "y" igual a "mx"+"b"
aquí ¿dónde está la "b"?
bueno la "b" es un 0 verdad, podríamos
verlo como menos "x" + 0
así que cuando "x" es igual a 0
"y" es igual a 0
y por lo tanto nuestra intersección con el eje "y" está en el origen.
Ahora la pendiente otra vez, tenemos que verlo
como menos 1 por "x" verdad,
entonces la pendiente es negativo y es 1
así que cuando nos movemos uno a la
derecha bajamos 1 en "y"
nos movemos 1 a la derecha bajamos 1 en "y"
¿ok? o bien si nos vamos a la izquierda subimos 1 en "y"
¿ok? deben tener signos distintos, si nos movemos a la derecha baja, si nos movemos a la izquierda sube
ok, más o menos puedes imaginar esta línea dividiendo a los cuadrantes.
Ahora vamos a hacer el último
vamos a hacer este de aquí "y" es igual a 3.75
así que aquí lo que estamos viendo bueno...
aquí "y" es igual a "mx"+"b"
pero no vemos el término en "x" se ha ido,
ha desaparecido
bueno, en realidad es que esto lo podemos reescribir como, 0 por "x" más 3.75
ok ,ahora esto tiene sentido, la pendiente es 0 no importa cuánto nos cambiemos en "x"
"y" no cambia, así que delta "y" entre delta "x" es igual a 0
no importa cuánto nos movamos en la dirección "x"
nuestra intersección con el eje "y" es 3.75
que está, como más o menos por aquí...
ok
y como al cambiar "x" "y" no cambia
entonces siempre va a ser 3.75
es decir, es una línea horizontal al eje "x"
ok, y es igual a 3.75
Espero les haya sido útil esto